hey everyone this is Steve landrope with
collider and we are here in I'm saying
collider again the collider Sundance
Studio which is sponsored by Saratoga
Springwater huge thank you to Saratoga
covering Sundance is expensive we really
appreciate our sponsors
um I'm here with uh for landscape with
invisible hand uh I'm so excited to see
this because this is my genre sci-fi is
is the one
um and I'm so so excited to see this
tomorrow when it's going to Premiere
here at Sundance
um everyone watching this won't have
seen it yet so I hate doing the generic
thing but how have you been describing
it to friends and family so landscape
with invisible hand is a kind of
interesting Riff on the Alien Invasion
genre where the alien invasion is a
fully economic one the aliens come and
they don't dominate Earth through
military force they take over through
the free market they make everything we
make better and faster than we do and
within that world it's the story of
young artist and a young woman that he
meets at his school played by Kylie here
and their attempts to save their
struggling families by monetizing their
courtship and their young love
uh it's what I really am looking forward
to is this is unlike any movie that I've
like this is not like a synopsis I've
heard from for and you know movies have
been been made for over 100 years I've
never heard this one which is one of the
reasons why I'm excited but I am curious
for you what was it like uh reading the
script for the first time how much were
you told in advance like what this story
would be and how much was it you
discovering it in the script yeah
um
I don't know I remember like when I
first just got the audition and it you
know gives a little brief like synopsis
and I was like
hmm
it's kind of weird it's kind of like it
felt like very like odd and then I got
it and then I spoke to Corey about the
character and everything I read the
script and I mean my initial thought was
like I've never heard or read anything
like this in my entire life
and I was mainly excited because aliens
and I love sci-fi and I thought it was
like I was so excited to work with like
Corey because I love his previous work
but I don't know my previous thoughts
were just like I've never seen anything
like this in my life and I was so
excited I'm curious for you what is it
like you've obviously you've booked gigs
you've been working but what is it like
when you are meeting a director for the
first time either on Zoom or in person
and you really want the gig and like you
know what I mean like how nervous are
you on that Zoom call and how much are
you sort of just it gonna be what it's
going to be yeah I'm I'm always nervous
for everything so of course I was super
nervous but then as soon as it's usually
like I usually overthink and then as
soon as I get into it it's totally
normal and fine and Corey's like the
nicest like funniest like warmest
director ever so it was just immediately
like I was so comfortable and like fine
and like ready to talk about the
character and everything and it was
great uh for obviously casting this
movie is uh I mean it's everything you
know who you're gonna put in the film so
talk a little bit about how you decided
on your lead actors and also just the
casting process in general I've spoken
to a lot of directors and they say
within like a few seconds they can
sometimes tell this is the right person
is that the same for you yeah I think
the easiest and best casting decisions
are usually the most instinctual the
most sort of immediate and gut decisions
I certainly had that about Kylie so they
had that about Asante black who plays uh
our lead and um and yeah I think one of
the things that really struck me about
Kylie's audition uh is that we we gave
her two really kind of high degree of
difficulty scenes with a lot of very
strange unusual Concepts that make
perfect sense by the time you reach them
in the movie uh but Kylie has this
amazing talent for making it seem as
though she's just coming up with these
Baroque written sentences on her own and
making them sound like the most natural
thing in the world uh and she also just
had uh just an enormous sort of
naturalness
um and and kind of a natural magnetism
that were were certainly important
things uh for this role one of the
things about uh again I haven't seen the
film but obviously when you have a film
like this where you have aliens and you
are depicting a near future world
there's going to be
um CGI involved and there's going to be
how you're going to have to you know
this is not a cheap film you can't make
this for like a million dollars you know
so talk a little bit about how you where
and when you wanted to spend the money
to uh amplify your story yeah it's a
great question because it's not a cheap
tiny movie it certainly has scope and
scale but also one of the things that
really drew me to this story and it's
based on a wonderful book by Mt Anderson
um is that it's also super intimate so
it has
um sort of a a big budget shell and a
and a moving smaller movie heart I
suppose hopefully the Best of Both
Worlds
um and we wanted to be very tactical
with how we deployed our pretty limited
resources on this movie
and one of my very first calls was to a
gentleman named Eric Deboer who was the
VFX supervisor on okja bong Joon Ho's
movie he he worked with bong uh to
create this amazing Super Pig in that
moment in that movie which was one of
the first times for me that I've been
watching a movie and thought you know
visual effects has really reached a
point technologically and with the
artist making it that uh if you do it
well if you do it in a kind of uh
carefully planned out way and you you
mix the real and the CG you really can
create a character that doesn't uh
constantly have you fighting the sort of
suspension of disbelief that you might
have with even a very good puppet or
something like that
um and so I worked really closely with
Eric both developing the design for
these creatures and then realizing it
throughout the process and they're not
on screen an enormous amount of the
movie but they certainly took the Lion's
Share of kind of planning and resources
uh and ultimately they they really exist
to give our our human actors a chance to
shine uh and really uh tell the story of
this movie by the way for people that
have not seen okja phenomenal and
changed my eating habits I hope so I
literally changed my my life because of
that film are you a vegetarian uh I I
don't mean to get into this I don't I
don't eat red meat basically uh like uh
it's so rare
um and it's from that film it literally
changed it certainly changed the degree
of guilt I have about my eating habits
and and some amount of mining habits yes
if you have not seen it I strongly
recommend it just throwing that out
there so what I am curious if you could
talk a little bit about one of the
things I read that you wanted to design
aliens that had never been depicted on
screen before so how did you end up with
the final look and why was it important
to you to obviously create something
that had never been done
yeah well I'm sure that's to some degree
the the goal of anyone that sets out to
create a new creature I think one of our
unique challenges and opportunities was
this is based on a book based on a book
that has not previously been adapted
into any visual medium and the book is
very careful about describing only what
it really needs to describe about these
creatures and leaving the rest of your
imagination which is totally the right
tactic in a literary World
um but obviously we're working in a
visual medium so we wanted to create
something that preserved the kind of
mystery of these creatures that the book
uh pulls off so well but also gives you
something that feels very tactile and
very real and without giving too much
away about them it just it was endless
iteration uh uh working with a bunch of
really talented concept artists and just
not uh not settling until we'd found
the design that felt kind of perfectly
simple and perfectly different
um and uh our our kind of Mantra and
creating those creatures there's a
there's a straight line in the book
about how they they don't look much like
any existing creature they look if
anything like sort of squat coffee
tables uh and so coffee tables was our
sort of um was our was our sacred phrase
in designing these creatures I'm curious
for you when you were looking at the
schedule and you're looking at the
script schedule what was the day that
you had circled like this could be a
really challenging day for me oh
um
there's there's a scene where Adam and
Chloe Mina Santi go up
I don't know what I can say
you could you could you can spoil they
go up to where the the aliens are and
um they have a conversation with one
um and I just I I didn't know how
challenging that would be because
um you know you're speaking to a
something that's not there I mean it was
there like physically but like like it's
speaking back to you but I wasn't
actually like
speaking back to us so
um I don't think I was concerned but I
was just a little like I don't know how
that's going to go I've never I've never
really done so much work with um like
CGI VFX so and the whole process was
non-existent seed Partners yeah with the
non-existent scene partner but it was
great it went fine
uh if you don't mind me asking how long
did you actually have to shoot the movie
something like
34 days do you have a better memory than
me I think it was about 30 yeah it's the
longest I've ever had on a movie but it
as it always does felt very tight uh for
what we had to accomplish in that period
yeah 30 for people that don't realize I
mean there's some movies here at
Sundance that were shot in 14 days but
like a big budget movie could be 70 days
yes and obviously 100 and something but
you know 34 is a is a tight schedule you
know so what was the what was the
the things that you were really nervous
about being able to pull off with the
time that you had on set yeah I think as
Kylie alluded to there was we had to
kind of develop a new uh not unique in
the history of Cinema but certainly
unique for a lot of us
um first time for a lot of us we had to
develop a way of working with these
creatures that were not physically
present on set we had a system of sort
of proxy statues and a really brilliant
sound team
um that that had all sorts of tips and
tricks and ways of achieving that
um but certainly those days were tricky
and then it was just a lot of story to
get through and uh I think it helps when
you have really prepared actors and and
great actors that you just don't need to
uh you know as a director you need to
know when you need to go for those extra
you know 10 takes or something like that
but it's also a real skill in knowing
when you have it and that was certainly
important on a tighter schedule like
this so one of the things about this is
it takes place in the near future so
what is some of like the near future
technology that we currently don't have
that you wanted to pay effect in the
film
uh it's a good question something we
thought a lot about because I think my
aim What drew me to this book was it's
kind of uh
metaphorical uh sort of aphoristic
approach to the Future it was uh it was
not an interest in designing a whole lot
of very uh kind of fascinating whiz-bang
technology I think one of the
interesting ideas of the book is that
when aliens come they they bring this
incredible technology uh but only a
handful of the richest humans can afford
it and our story almost exclusively
focuses on the rest of the humans that
are left down on the Earth's surface and
have to make do with technology that's
not all that dissimilar from what we
have now
we wanted to create some interesting
little pieces of technology that that
feel very sort of emotionally real and
feel like sort of maybe increasingly
surreal bizarre uncomfortable versions
of some of the technology that we that
we love to hate in our own lives today
uh one of the things again that I read
that uh hopefully the film when you
leave the theater you're going to want
to talk about it you're going to want to
maybe debate so is that one of the
things that you hope that people take
away
I think it always is I think certainly
with this movie
um and and in post one of the things
that we really enjoy doing was my script
was a little bit wordier than the final
movie I think that's not unusual
um but there was a little bit more of
characters expounding on the themes of
the movie and I think when you have
great actors uh and and and talented DP
and and a great team that can do more
visual storytelling more storytelling
with a look uh you can get rid of some
of that Exposition you can get not not
just Exposition about the world but you
can get rid of some of that thematic
Exposition and so we really tried to
whittle the movie down to something
um
fully fleshed out but still sort of
mysterious and with audience with room
for the audience to fill in
um their own ideas about why things have
happened and to and to debate it walking
out of the theater for sure because I
haven't seen the film yet and I want to
ask you some more questions I'm going to
ask you some separate subject if you
don't mind please
um so uh you were obviously you play
Young Beth on Yellowstone which is a
super popular show yeah how has being on
that series have you noticed it in real
life when you're at like you know the
supermarket that there's a lot of people
that want to talk to you about the
character
yeah I mean I've I've been on since
season one which is crazy so
it's definitely been an experience no
one expected it to be this like massive
like hit TV show so it's like cowboys
Cowboy TV show in Hollywood you know so
it's like very like unexpected I guess
um I am originally from Texas so
whenever I went back to Texas I've
definitely noticed a lot more people are
like you're young Beth from Yellowstone
or like there's like there's like
Yellowstone merch in like the airports
or like it's it's actually crazy how
much like Yellowstone merch exists um in
Texas but yeah I for sure noticed like a
massive growth how does it work in terms
of because you've been in some episodes
how early on do you know that they're
gonna need you for an episode is it
sometimes really last minute
foreign
yeah I feel like it can be most of the
time it's it's like at least a couple
man months in advance
so like it's like it's like pretty 50 50
like sometimes it's like oh we need you
like next week or like sometimes it's
like we'll need you in two months for a
day you know what I mean
uh I had one other question for you uh I
am really looking forward to a certain
Joaquin Phoenix film that's coming out
in the not so distant future yeah um so
can you talk a little bit about being
part of that film because I I'm very
excited for it yeah
um
I mean it's CR it's insane I still don't
I still don't believe that I'm actually
a part of such an amazing movie
um
I mean I don't know I can't really say
much about it but the process was
amazing Joaquin is so talented he's like
one of obviously one of my biggest
Inspirations I feel like that's a given
um
and R is so creative and I can't wait
for everyone to see it it's insane one
of the things about Joaquin
um and I've spoken to him a number of
times is that he really uh he's a very
he disappears in the role he's told me
that like sometimes when he's on set
like he will just be in it and it like
it's all of a sudden you'll hear like
you know uh lunch and it'll sort of wake
up a little bit and then he submerges
again like he's told me about his
process and it's it's fascinating so
what is it like to work with someone on
set who is really such a gifted actor
and gives so much of his soul to a
performance I think it's honestly like
it's it's very helpful to me and it's
just everyone on set because it is such
a crazy movie with very
sort of weird um subject so
so it's very it's just helpful to get
everyone sort of in the moment and in
the in the scene and no one feels weird
about anything they have to do because
everything's everyone's just like fully
and everyone was so passionate about
everything they did and it was great
yeah I would imagine that working with
someone like that and as because you've
worked on a number of things now it's
really helped you as a performer and you
know to not be maybe a self-conscious on
set yeah 100 100 I feel like I've never
done a role like
um
who I portrayed in and Bo's afraid so I
was definitely a little nervous going
into it but then Honestly by the end of
it I was just like totally out there not
self-conscious just doing anything I I
could and it was great
um what I'm very curious so you've
directed I'm I'm a big fan of your work
if someone has actually never seen
anything that actually it's a question
for both of you if someone has never
seen anything you've done before what is
the first thing you want them watching
and why
oh it's like having to pick between
children 100 question uh I love them all
equally for different reasons I
certainly uh my first movie
thoroughbreds will always have a special
place in my heart it was the first time
I was here at Sundance
um and I I just never experienced it
came out of playwriting and and the
largest thing the largest performance
I'd ever had prior to the debut if their
obradz was in a 50-seat basement theater
uh in uh downtown New York and so that
was surreal for me
um and then bad education my second
movie
um was also just a wonderful privilege
working with Hugh Jackman and Allison
Janney and just a fantastic stacked cast
um so I I couldn't tell people where to
dive in if you're more of a
psychological Thriller person start with
thoroughbreds if you're more of a true
crime drama dark comedy person start
with bad education
oh I'd say is a very hard question
um I really like Yellowstone because you
can really see my growth and I start I
mean I think I started the show when I
was like 12 and the most recent season
and I'm 18 so
that's fun to start with and I don't
know landscape isn't out yet but
landscape perhaps I wasn't sure if you
were gonna say landscape I was curious I
was debating I assumed that was uh you
know present company excluded that's the
obvious place to start at
um so I am curious though with this now
that you're in now that the movie's done
obviously I'm sure you're thinking about
what am I going to do next so are you do
you know what you want to do next I am
writing uh my next movie and uh I am a
very fast writer when I have kind of
figured out all the the key points of
the movie I'm a wonderfully slow writer
uh in figuring out the sort of core of
what the movie is and that was certainly
true with this one there were many sort
of covid field years of development on
this uh so it's still got a little while
to germinate but uh it's going to be a
very different thing from any of the
three I've done to this point and uh
excited to get into that are you one of
these people that can develop multiple
things at the same time or are you very
laser focused on one I'd say closer to
laser focused uh I certainly uh I do
have a couple irons in the fire at any
given time I usually have one kind of
baby at a time but I can split my
attention to some degree but I have
friends that can truly juggle five or
six projects at a time and I'm in awe uh
and and envious of those people it's so
fascinating because I I know a lot of
like Guillermo Toro he will develop like
eight things at the same time and he
talks about like he just told me
recently that like something that he
wanted to do that he's passionate about
got turned down I'm like how F does
Guillermo's projects get good but that
tells you everything yerimo's getting
turned down but that tells you about
Hollywood yes where even like a major
filmmaker who is won Academy Awards when
you know he still can't get certain
things made that's why you know well you
know well absolutely it's you know it's
an expensive business uh and I think
we're always grateful for the studios
the independent financiers all the
people that that allow us to make these
movies uh but certainly and I think as
the ambition of of the movies you're
making grows the difficulty of getting
them made grows and I think there's
something good and humbling about that
that even directors much further along
in their careers than I am still have to
be grateful for each Movie that that
gets greenlit because it is it does feel
like a miracle every time it happens and
Apollo I apologize for not knowing is
landscape for sale at Sundance uh no
landscape is with MGM so the first time
I'm not taking a movie to a festival to
sell and I highly recommend it it's a
much more relaxing process so what is uh
the plan is there a plan yet for release
I will be coming out this year I can't
disclose when yet
um but yeah I'm excited uh I'm excited
to to get into that later this year I am
excited to talk to you when I've seen it
to ask more specific questions for
example also to you uh but you know what
I mean um but listen I I really want to
thank you both so much for coming in uh
and talking with me and I really hope
you have an awesome Sundance thank you
so much it's been a real pleasure thank
you